i've only tried to watch it because yeah
i watched that
did you watch it yeah i didn't finish it
but i watched most of it last night
watched the whole goddamn thing i mean
it was good it was definitely a good
story
i whenever i see those reenactment
scenes um
i want to do one of those okay you want
to do it right now
no like for a documentary like i want to
be cast as one of the
re-enactees yeah yeah no i i
i kind of felt the same way but they
were really good that they were good
good yeah like the guy
what was his name nick what was the
singer rick singer the guy who played
rick singer
killed it like i thought that could have
been an hbo show or something
yeah then the he had he had great um
all of them they they really nailed that
awkward pausing on the phone
yeah and i i kind of liked that sorry go
ahead were you about to do it
yeah just the whole like they'd be like
what do you mean
like they had those good little like in
between like
yeah it's cause i think they did those
conversations verbatim
yeah yeah cause you can tell they're not
scripted dialogue
they didn't flow they were really
awkward which is like what
normal phone calls are like people say
weird [ __ ] yeah so the guy was like not
that like they kept going on about how
like good of a salesman he was and how
you know he was a smooth talker and he
knew how to like uh you know harp on
people's
weaknesses in the middle of a
conversation and then it cuts to the
conversation and he's like
yeah i'm in london cool cold there yeah
i'm in london
why'd you say that twice you know like
just weird [ __ ] yeah i mean i can't
you know these one-way roads it's so
weird
like it's just a little bit off
everything he said was like just
weird you know clearly was not tv
dialogue
also the guy playing him had way more
charisma
than the actual him the actual him that
guy's eyeballs
were stone like there was nothing
just he just looked so empty-headed
yeah and and that like little pitch
video for his website
so funny i take my students and i
that i'm like how did anyone give this
guy money
yeah i know he's like we're we are a
multinational corporation
specializing in making sure your child
fully sees their potential and then like
they're talking
i'm talking to the woman that he dated
and she was like yeah he was like so
charming and i went on his website after
and i was like you watched that [ __ ]
video and didn't immediately
ghost that guy yeah that part was crazy
[ __ ] out
oh like older people have a different
definition of charisma
i think that's what it is yeah are you
just a guy that speaks
his mind you know yeah that old school
confidence where you don't blink
and you don't emote i mean that's
probably what it is i think like
the probably all these rich dudes who
are so used to people being scared
of them because they're they got money
right yes
on the phone and he's like listen it's
75k
if you want your kid to ace the sats
it's 75k
yeah it's like he was pretty uh you know
i don't know he was pretty like
determinate no that's not a word at all
i don't know no yeah
no he was he was pretty direct he was
like he spoke definitively like it was
just like
these are the terms [ __ ] he's like
listen you can use the front door
your kid's not [ __ ] smart enough to
get in i'm just telling you that
straight up right now your kid's an
idiot
he's not getting into harvard okay he's
a dunce okay he's getting
c's and d's okay you can't go in the
back door
because that's not a guarantee so we got
to go in my side door my side door
let's go on my side cool 500k
i also feel that the rich guys in a way
you know he he might have hit
on a subtle you know
they they don't usually get strong-armed
they might have liked it
you know someone telling them how it is
it seemed like they did that's what i'm
saying
listen here because i'll return to that
this is the price they go oh
i like this guy no one's talked to me
like that that's what high level
business is it's just like
who can bend over the other one yeah you
know
yeah yeah these guys are like
multi-multi-millionaires and they're
like it kind of feels good to be the
beta
yeah for once you know that's what they
look for
in business after a while once they've
made their millions they don't really
care about the money they're looking for
that
that good ben bend over experience
they want to be bent over they've been
doing the bending at a point yeah
yeah yeah that's that's that's all it
takes to reach that point as investors
as investors will probably reach that
point yeah where we get sick of
all the good investments we're doing
you know good investment you know bud
i'll tell you we used to do the bending
now we want to get bent
you know you got to give them you got to
give that guy some credit rick
singer or whatever oh ballsy as [ __ ]
ballsy as [ __ ] to take on
you know the the entire college
admissions process
and the way that [ __ ] has been working
forever
and to find those little loopholes and
to pay the people off on the inside
and to slowly build his network like
obviously it's
immensely shitty but at the same time
it's like this dude
dude got balls that's a crazy thing that
he was actually able to
successfully do yeah i think
the greatest crime in all this is
these schools just get to like run their
hands and be like oh no we didn't
nah we didn't do that
because like the greatest crime is that
the schools
aren't like aren't
you know uh tried for the same thing
it's like they do the same [ __ ]
they just big people write these checks
to donate these buildings and then they
get a second look at their kid and it's
like but why isn't that just the same
thing
yeah you know all they do is they just
can the the people who
are associated and then if names weren't
named then uh or if there's no proof and
they say nah man get [ __ ] outta here
like that that dude who
didn't do [ __ ] he didn't do [ __ ] that
that
that sailing sailing guy yeah the fact
that he's a
he's a felon he eat bro a felony
did he get convicted he plea he had to
plead guilty
what so he didn't serve time so he
pleads guilty
and he pays a 10k fine he is confined to
his home for like
six months or something he's got a
two-year probation
and his lawyer is like you know i've
talked to him and you know he's back in
school
and he's better than he was he's better
than he was he's at home with his kids
i'm thinking how is that not soul
crushing
i mean it is the way that guy talks oh
my god
he's like a puppy he's like and i uh i
i fortunately i um
you know i unfortunately had the worst
phone call of my life and
uh now i'm a convicted felon
like no it's like no no he's not that
guy's nowhere
yeah he's nowhere close to a felon man i
think that's the shittiest part
that the schools get to just go nah nah
we didn't do it
yeah no that wasn't yeah and then the
whole the way that they used the olivia
jade footage
it's just so like dude that like
clip of her saying how much she hates
school
so right after it's like oh man
i know that was all over twitter before
but for them to take that and like
and clearly add that narrative in where
they're like trying to paint her like an
awful person
yeah well the other part that
obviously you know i wouldn't understand
um
but i think either of us would easily
forget is like
acceptance rate that part completely
escaped me the first time the story came
out or whatever
um and like when the girl said
oh yeah when i saw her and her sister
got accepted i thought damn that's crazy
and it kind of clicked it clicked with
me like oh [ __ ] yeah
you don't really see that like it is
pretty rare that like
siblings would land at the same school
like sort of
no i mean not if you're like legacy
didn't her mom go
to usc or her dad or something i don't
know no no neither of them went to
college
yeah yeah so that's what that's what the
big deal was yeah so then it's rare yes
oh but if you if your parents went then
well i mean if your parents went it
probably means they've been donating for
a long time which means
shot of going and so that's why you see
like a lot of siblings go to the same
college if they if the parents went to
the good cause schools are just a
[ __ ] pyramid scheme man this [ __ ] is
crazy
at least like the ivy leagues and stuff
i mean it's you know what's crazy is
that like i was
listening to this podcast and the guy
the host is like one of the smartest
people i've ever listened to like the
guy's like a legitimate genius
and he went to ucla and or he applied to
ucla i think when he was
like college aged and the acceptance
rate at that point was
like 60 or 56
or something like that dang he didn't
get in this guy's like super [ __ ]
smart he didn't get in
now ucla acceptance rate i think is six
percent
it's like impossible to go to college
to one of those colleges that was like
one of the main points that they
uh wanted to wait 16 hold on 16
no no the total acceptance rate across
u.s campuses
oh yeah wait wait 16
that's what it is sorry
16 that's insane
it's pretty insane i mean it's hard as
[ __ ] to go to a good school you know
mm-hmm
well at least when of those especially
it's like impossible the big ten or
whatever
yeah that was one of the main points
though that a guy makes at the end of
the documentary where he says
the quality of the education isn't any
different there's plenty of schools in
america that
offer you the same education it's just
this [ __ ] like
system that they create and one guy says
the thing that's [ __ ] up about all
this is that
these schools are going to claim
prestige because
you know oh look at this look at all
these celebrities are will in
businessmen that were willing to go to
prison just to get
investors yeah and investors oh oh oh i
see what you're saying yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean it's the that's
what matters with college
most the most the biggest thing that
matters is the credential
right now i mean you can access every
harvard class online for free and it's
been like that for like
10 years now every single one for free
you can have a harvard
education for free on your own time
but it doesn't matter no one's gonna no
one's gonna look at that on a resume and
be like oh what the [ __ ]
it's like the just the name that [ __ ]
matters and it's messed up
yeah it's just messed up dude and
frankly it's my stop
yeah i had like my last semester of
college i had this
realization that i was like dude i've
just been paying to go to
a glorified community college i've been
robbed
i was so pissed yeah
i was so pissed dude i went to csun
oh yeah yeah what was that i walked
around the campus
it was beautiful actually i loved it it
was a it's a
you know it looked like a cool like the
you know the pool is like all sunken and
you know what i'm talking about like a
student area or something like that
where
there was a pool but there was a walkway
it's like above it
you know um did you not go to
campus very often i mean campus for me
it's like i just went to like the
business area of the campus like
the ambassador side the investor side
basically yeah
nah it's that it's a weird school bro
just because it's like it's a commuter
school like
not many people live near campus or like
or
or they do but um living on campus is
like
you you probably moved from somewhere
like
yeah but uh that's not that's not a
great way of illustrating what i'm
trying to say what i mean is
i don't think many people move to csun
so it's like it's kind of limited so to
live there like it
you have to be a sort of a specific
person um
whereas i feel like other larger
colleges you know
people move there like from all over
yeah
but yeah that's why like the parking
structures are [ __ ] insane
and like the parking is they're huge
yeah that's that's what kelsey said
she's like parking was
a hot commodity it's like it was crucial
in your experience or like basically
like defined your day
you couldn't find parking uh the time
you got there [ __ ] your whole [ __ ] up
yeah it was like dude how many times
i had to park literally two blocks from
campus
and walk that [ __ ] in some days like i'd
i'd go
and if i did like laps and i couldn't
get a spot i'm like not going to class
just not doing it later you didn't have
like a a cool little rip stick or
anything you could just
nah there was one dude on campus who had
that
and lydia everybody everybody was like
yeah look at all
[ __ ] high school boy over here but
everybody wanted it yeah
everybody wanted it yeah because
you know yeah the the campus is [ __ ]
huge
it was nice though really nice i thought
it was a good that little like
area in front of the library or whatever
yeah the quad
yeah something quad el quad i liked it
that's a nice spot yeah they use that
[ __ ] in star trek
i forget which one but that was cool
wow that's dope yeah yeah
so um yeah guys you don't have to you
don't have to go to ivy league i think
that's the point of this whole
conversation
yeah and i think that there i think that
i
see it starting right now there's like a
um
a lot of like innovation in the college
space i think a lot of people are trying
to
um innovate in in terms of like exactly
what i was saying where it's like
college
the only reason people go or the only
reason two goes for the network and for
the credential and i think that
that being the case i don't think that
you'll have to actually go to a big name
school to get those two things in the
future
no i think there's gonna be a lot of
ways that you can
you know earn or i guess like people
like shorthand like people like
to look at a resume and be like oh you
studied with this person or you did this
thing or you
did you did this thing in a couple words
yeah just like uh that now validates you
yeah and i think there's gonna be other
ways to do that in the future like yeah
very
close very soon
you